-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers
and this is "Late Night."
We are back from a week
of hiatus
and happy to be here.
Let's get to the news.
President Biden was set
to discuss
his infrastructure
proposal today
with the top
Republican negotiator,
who I think is Joe Manchin
In an op-ed yesterday,
Democratic Senator Joe Manchin
announced that he
would be voting
against a new voting rights bill
and reiterated his support
for the filibuster.
So, when I say he's Democratic
that's just like
the party he's in.
Wyoming Congresswoman Liz Cheney
said, in a new interview,
that former President Trump'
incitement
of the January attack
on the Capitol is
"the most dangerous thing
a president has done."
Previously, it was go to a play.
[ Laughter ]
So, I'm glad
Scollins didn't change.
[ Laughter ]
after a week off.
And he spent the whole wee
in sensitivity training.
[ Laughter ]
Former President Trump's
daughter-in-law Lara Trump
announced, over the weekend,
that she will not run
for a Senate seat
in North Carolina,
due to her young children,
because she's seen firsthand
what happens when you neglec
Trump children.
[ Laughter ]
Former President Trump's blo
shut down permanently last week.
Oh, come on, you're not supposed
to shut down blogs.
You're supposed
to slowly stop posting,
'til you forget you have one
Then, a year later,
you do one of those,
"Hey, guys, sorry I haven'
updated in a while" posts,
even though literally
no one's been asking
and no one could care less
A spokesperson for British
Prime Minister Boris Johnson
recently announced
that he married his fiancé
in a small, private ceremony
Just what the world needed -
another, less effective,
Johnson & Johnson.
[ Laughter ]
Today was former Vice Presiden
Mike Pence's 62nd birthday
despite Donald Trump's
best efforts.
Former Vice President
Mike Punce recent--
"Punce."
[ Laughter ]
I got it right
the previous joke.
-Yeah, yeah, you had it.
-So like I know what it is
[ Laughter ]
You guys remember this punce
["putz"]
[ Laughter ]
Former Vice President Mike Pence
recently spoke
at a Lincoln-Reagan Dinner
in New Hampshire
about the January attack
on the Capitol.
He didn't intend to,
but that's just
how flashbacks work.
Officials in Los Angeles Count
are reportedly set to vote soo
on a law that prohibits
feeding peacocks
and make it punishable
by up a $1,000 fine
or six months in jail.
Incidentally, "feeding the
peacock" is also what I call
making 200 shows a year.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, and she has an appetite!
A 30-year-old woman in Texas
was arrested
for trespassing recently,
after she allegedly posed
as her 13-year-old daughte
and spent the day at her school.
Damn, lady, why didn't you jus
enjoy high school
when you were there?
Wait, oh, so she's 30.
Her daughter's 13.
Oh, okay.
Okay, I see.
Enjoy yourself.
And, finally, Amazon
CEO Jeff Bezos announced today
in an Instagram post,
that he and his brother will b
on the first crew space flight
of his private rocket compan
later this year.
If he wants to see space
so badly,
he should just open one
of his packages.
And that, you guys,
was a monologue.
And I think
it's pretty clear, uh,
we still got it.
[ Laughter ]
You know, I do want to say
you know, I gave Scollins
a hard time.
He had a very hard week
because, Friday,
we were just talking about
it was National Doughnut Day
Obviously,
that's the kind of thing
that he would write
a hundred jokes about
and he just had to spend i
alone in his home,
hopefully, at least,
eating a free doughnut.